an air strike has destroyed houses in
the B refugee camp some 15 bodies have
been pulled from the rubble alzer's
Hisham zakut sent us this report from
the
camp we witness the same scenes Israeli
warplanes pour down tons of lethal
explosives and missiles on residential
areas unsuspecting innocent civilians
Sheltering in their homes with the
target this is B Refugee Campa in the
heart of Gaza Strip densely populated
buildings crammed on top of each other
most of the buildings are shanties
others built in bricks and cement but
all are totally destroyed leveled to the
ground this deep crater you see was once
four buildings our camera will pan left
and right you can see the entire area in
Ruins this simple residential area was
pounded by more than a dozen
missiles
it was home to innocent civilians in the
heart of a refugee camp all civilians
who were in the area were killed no
survivors ferocious air
strikes as we speak the warplanes and
drones are still
hovering my family and I were sitting at
home all of a sudden we heard a huge
explosion everything was flying around
we could not see anything but dust and
smoke that was my home totally in Ruins
I not know what to say we are helpless
it cannot even be compared to an
earthquake this is massive the whole
area is turned upside down in a second
we thank God he is our
Rock what are you doing what are you
looking for I am searching for my
sister I can only see ruins how can you
recognize your home from all this
Rubble I recognized from that building
standing over there we found a Survivor
but my sister and niece are buried
underneath may they rest in
peace who have you
lost my two sisters along with all their
children we are helpless we cannot
remove heavy concrete it's too late even
if we find them they must be dead now
may God accept them in his Mercy all we
have to say ISD
alhamdulillah the pictures are the same
every time there's a bombing destroying
neighborhoods and killing innocent
people